by the time I'd done 6 months
sober I really started feeling the
benefits I started sleeping better I was
handling stressful situations better my
relationship was better my relationship
with my family was better my
relationship with my work was better and
I just sort of said to myself let's do a
year let's get through the first year
and then that would be a wonderful
achievement and then by the time I'd
crossed that annual Mark I was done I
was like I've never going to drink again
cuz this is the best version of myself
it was my go-to to celebrate and my
go-to to commiserate you're constantly
like this which means that you always
have a reason to be drinking or I felt
like I always had a reason to be
drinking I was never a bad drunk or
anything like that I just when I started
I just couldn't stop